a new record temperature has been set
the village of conningsby in
lincolnshire has hit
40.3 degrees celsius this afternoon that
is now
the uk's record
temperature
just let that sink in for a little bit
it's getting hotter i mean it's nearly
five o'clock in the evening but
temperatures in some parts of the uk
still
creeping up um
professor galea
i mean you know it's not a competition
nobody wants to break these records
today and it's really grim it's really
grim out there today it is going to
change tomorrow
but as we prepare for
a new kind of normal
how much more of this do you think we
will see and how frequently
i i think there's a good chance that
we're going to be seeing this sort of
thing every
summer season
um and what's even more concerning on
the continent in europe the fire seasons
were
strictly restricted to the high summer
but now what we're seeing in europe
because of climate change is that the
fire season is spreading to to occur
outside high summer and even outside of
summer
and we're reaching a point in mainland
europe where the fire season could be
all year round um we're not anywhere
near that in the uk
but
certainly
in in the summer season what we're
seeing on the sky screens now could
become the norm uh and uh and we need to
prepare for that both in our planning
and in in our behavior as i said uh tote
days of total fire ban um uh you know
that should we should be looking at
introducing that in the uk to remove the
chances or reduce the chances of
accidentally starting fires
in the patched dry environment